les 75 ans de pierre boulez le
compositeur et chef d'orchestre français
a donné pour l'occasion un concert à la
cité de la musique michel mompontet yves
jenca bien commençons ce serait un peu
comme un jardinier mais un jardinier
dont le jardin resterait perpétuellement
en friche
et cela uniquement parce que ce
jardinier le veut
est ce que boulez veut se fait
immédiatement
dutil corrigé de sa main en pleine
répétition les imperfections de cette
partition pour rester coûte que coûte et
maintenant être du labyrinthe sonore
qu'ils n'installent c'est une musique
qu'on découvre nous en même temps quand
même temps que lui alors lui l'a fait
travailler nous on la découvre donc il
faut s'ajuster il faut trouver ses
repères auditifs il faut il ya un vrai
travail de création qu'on n'a pas sur du
béton of surduts surtout répertoire
qu'on connaît qui est qui qui roule tout
seul est le 34 c'est parti le 3/4 et
c'est parti qu'on aille pas s'y
méprendre boulet sait faire et
magistralement
mais ici vous allez la rampe blond
conventionnel parmi ceux qui lui a
toujours plu à lui c'est d'être de son
temps
et de faire une musique qui prend le
risque de n'être justement que de son
temps
c'est là son courage son côté aventurier
pour moi ce qui correspond davanture
rené char disait comment vivre sans
inconnus devant soi il faut que vraiment
tout à fait le faire et pire boulet à 75
ans demeure également un grand pédagogue
à ce qu'enfin homme qui par son
intelligence foudroyante a su orienter
accompagner cinq décennies de musiciens
et la santé et la vigueur et le pouvoir
me restera de faire quelque chose eh
bien je préfère disant continuer mon
activité est pensé dans le futur plutôt
que de réfléchir à tout ce qui s'est
passé pendant une cinquantaine d'années
et lui qui fut fêtée décor est honorée
comme aucun compositeur refuse toujours
de se retourner vers le passé
là où les gloires se fige où se
transmute bien comment ça ce serait un
peu comme un jardin mais un jardinier
et cela uniquement ce jardinier
est ce que voulait ce se fait
immédiatement
lucky corrigé raison d'une répétition
les imperfections de cette partition
voilà ça c'est mieux
et maintenant ça aussi
il installe cette musique qu'on découvre
nous en même temps quand même temps que
lui alors lui l'a fait travailler nous
on la découvre donc il faut s'ajuster il
faut trouver ses repères auditifs il
faut il ya un vrai travail de création
qu'on n'a pas sur du béton of sur dur
tout le répertoire qu'on connaît et qui
est qui qui roule tout seul les 34 ces
partis en car et c'est parti
image east
mais ici vous allez la rente non
conventionnels parce que les soupes et
apprendre de lui c'est s'est déroulé
et de serre et musique qui prend le
risque de n'être justement que de son
temps
c'est là son courage son côté aventure
pour moi ce qui correspond aventure rené
char disait comment vivre sans inconnus
devant soi il faut que vraiment tout à
fait le faire mais maria 75e et moirans
pédago qu'est ce qu'on peut
est ce qu'on peut faire ou meurs 26e
foudroyante a su pour rien qu en tant
que et la santé et la vigueur et le
pouvoir me restera de faire quelque
chose eh bien je préfère disant
continuer mon activité est pensé dans le
futur plutôt que de réfléchir à tout ce
qui s'est passé pendant une cinquantaine
d'années
public idées déco
toujours de se retourner
même d'ivoire se fige on se transmute